super super stoked we got evans evans
and ellen
come on super super stoked
my name's samuel leeds we got in the
house evans and ellen here
this guy this guy made financially free
in seven days
now i'm gonna get an update from these
folks what's happening
these guys have got energy next level
welcome welcome how you guys doing oh we
are so excited
my name's samuel leeds and this week you
may have seen evans
who i went to his house i helped him
become financially free
and he became financially free in seven
days flat
and people were like is this real how
did this work
i'd love to have an update in a few
months time well guess what i got him in
my house right now
evans and his wonderful girlfriend ellen
great to have you guys in the in the
house
what is happening we are great we have i
mean first thing because we have
privilege to be here in your house
thank you so much for having us it's
super exciting i mean to say it's a
dream it's an understatement
um we actually saw um a video of
somebody in windows on a wednesday
that's the main thing that made us feel
like we can do it we said one day we'll
be here on the so far i don't know
yeah one day one day that's so great
and and listen firstly massive
congratulations on your success
because you know what happened in that
week was was like
zero to hero it was just absolutely
incredible
um what was for and for anyone who's not
watched the video i'd suggest
after you've watched this video go back
and watch it but what was the process
of having me come and stay at your house
for a week
how did you get that to happen did you
get picked randomly
did i see you in the street and just
pointed like how did that happen how did
it come about
um well it was definitely a big price i
definitely paid a big price to come in
um for those who didn't watch
um there was obviously you you put a
post applying for the eviction which i
actually
i thought twice about applying
eventually i actually applied um
i got shortlisted to a video for the
video i actually went through
um the selection i really want to make a
statement and just show in the videos
like it doesn't really matter where you
came from
um out of the 10 we went through an
immense you know
training and uh you know um i'm stressed
to get here but yep i i got it for that
um by
by pretty much be one of the winners of
the eviction and i got seven days and
that seven days was my seven days of
magic just really changed
every single thing in my life yeah and
people ask me every day
literally like probably every hour can
you do a financial freedom challenge
with me
can you come and live with me for a week
and help me become financially free
because i'm kind of famous for it
i'm famous for starting again from
scratch becoming financially free i'm
famous for going and helping other
people do the same thing
but i think what's really important is
number one
like if you want if you want to get my
attention
you've got to do stuff first you know
you went through the eviction
process and even to get on the eviction
you applied you did a video
you put yourself out there enter it same
story they all massively put themselves
out there and also another thing is you
don't need
me to come and live in your house to
become financially free
you don't is me coming to stay with you
it's not like a lottery ticket
you've got to put the effort in yourself
i'm not going to just feel sorry for
somebody
who's not taking any action and god go
on then let's have a try you know i
can't make anyone financially free the
only person that can make someone
financially free
is that person themselves all i can do
is assist and encourage and show the way
to
so i think you know for anyone that's
watching this is thinking samuel can you
come and stay with me i'd say don't wait
for me to come and stay in the house
get to the crash course do the possible
right like you make one step i made 10.
yeah
i mean it's funny that you said that
because i actually had the same condo
with someone today
they were like how can i get into the
circle how can i be somebody
you know just like you i'm just like
look man samuel didn't pick michael i'm
the best looking guy or we're very good
friends we have anything in common
yeah 100 i'm just like look man i i paid
an unbelievable price and even if right
now you're not getting selected but i
really believe that you know
opportunity meets preparation if you're
getting ready if you're doing the things
that you can control
you have you have videos every single
day for free on youtube start off there
then pay one pound come to the crash
course get some more knowledge
and if you think you want to go one step
above find the money do the training
yeah um
i mean that's it anyone can do it yeah
absolutely so
so basically you got lucky by putting
yourself in the right place at the right
time with the support of ellen your
girlfriend
um came on the eviction got to the final
and then i just spontaneously decided i
was going to do a financial freedom
challenge
with all three of the finalists which by
the way was oh my goodness was freaking
exhausting
by the time you're one finished i was
like i have to do another two of these
holy moly just finished my third one
and my wife then had a baby so like now
i'm
i'm like second third day on paternity
and um
i can't believe that this year i've done
it because it's the hard weeks right
can you believe i did three of them um i
mean i can't believe because i know the
guys but if i didn't know they're gonna
be like
i can't believe that you physically did
that because it's definitely exhausting
yes um so that i mean that week i spent
with you i mean it's not directly but
indirectly i just learned
like even now you winning so big and you
just at the intensity that you're
working
like i'm obliged to work at the same
level so it's incredible i remember you
saying to me in that week you were like
i used to think that i worked hard yeah
you know ellen what did you think then
so i come around the house you knew i
was coming to the house
but your parents didn't right
so you're living at evans with ellen's
parents you didn't tell them i was
coming
i come round i'm like hey i'm here to
help evans become financially free
coming to live with you i'm so sorry it
looks like it might be a bit tricky this
week
i'm really sorry no i understand i
understand
so there's zero chance i'll be able to
sleep in the shed
it looks that way yeah you know isn't it
wonderful and your parents are like
whoa what the heck what's this right
what what from your point of view tell
me about that evening ellen and what
happened
oh they felt so bad after they felt so
bad they were like we rejected samuel
leeds and he was so lovely
um but yeah it was just like crazy times
i guess with you know where we're at
right now
but um no like i mean we just maybe
we're being too positive we would just
think like just trying it's just going
to work out somehow
you kind of you kind of took the you
know it's a good it's a good saying
where it says
you're better to get forgiveness than
permission
but the yeah easy but the problem was
you still needed permission you just
thought
bear to just cross your fingers and hope
you'll get permission at the last second
so basically i come around the house and
and your parents are like
really nice very very sweet i come in
for a cup of tea
but then with the pandemic with the the
jobs the house
the restrictions your parents like we
just
cannot have you living here for a week
the only exception would be if you sleep
in the shed which of course you won't do
and i'm like i will
i'll go in the chat and then oh
okay let me think on that one man i'm
like getting a little excited about
staying in the shed and he's like
second thought yeah you can't stay in
the shed either so uh
i don't know what else to say kind of
awkward funny thing is as well in some
of the comments
um you know i i saw a couple comments
which i was quite sad about it
they were like oh why would the parents
not let them almost as if their pet your
parents aren't supportive i was thinking
i know your parents like they're the
most important people ever and i love
the way when they were typing that went
live like what are the parents weren't
they supporting i was thinking
you wait because it was actually your
dad that then joint ventured with
evans on on on on deal which is just a
full circle beautiful story
um you know so that was the awkward
start
what was going on in your head evans
when when that what happened you know
what you know
the main reason why i did it because i
could never forget i was uh i was i was
15 years old and i was i was playing
football my mom is very protective she's
like don't play football you'll break
your leg
so i was so i was playing football um
without she knowing
so the crazy thing that happened is
actually made the national football team
for the under
for the under 19's at the time and she
never knew about it and we had to fly to
trinidad
all right so what i did is i applied for
a passport all this stuff she didn't
know about it
that they were flying to trinidad i got
the coach and the entire football team
to drive to my house
then come upstairs speak to my mom and
then ask my mom if i can go to trinidad
because then if i ask her she would say
no so i'm like that actually worked i
actually
did good i'd be very scared if i was
ellen though what could he do next you
know
sorry so i said look if someone if
samuel liz comes to my house and says
look i'm gonna help your son evans
become rich why would they say no um
oh so that clearly didn't work out but
it still works in the end if you just
believe
and do everything you can it will work
out but yeah it's true it kind of worked
out but evan's face though
because i was genuinely thinking we
might have to reschedule this yeah
and evans was like everything i could
see in his
face his heart just sank watch his
stomach
um you know were you thinking at one
point evans that genuinely we might have
to reschedule
yeah um but i mean i was willing to
literally do everything but if it means
we have to rent you know disposable
tents and sleeping you know sleeping
like
in the yard yeah because i really needed
that week i was uh i was
i was desperate for that week yeah so
there was a possibility of but i'm like
summer please whatever we have to do man
um and thankful to amanda you know i
actually stayed here
yeah and then you so you separated from
ellen yeah ellen was cheering you on
like crazy
um rooting for you from um you know from
from your parents house
so what happened then in the week
because um i mean honestly
it was people were watching at the time
saying is this real is it legit
like how is this happening how you doing
it's so fast so what was that what did
we do what was the first thing so you
arrive here
what happens yeah so i mean what we did
was uh was it was just
too much of a big question i think what
we did not do i think we did every
single thing but when we came
um the good thing that i like and it's
something that obviously i heard many
people who successful say
we actually structured the plan so we
had a plan as to what we really wanted
to get out of it
uh we did get things that we didn't plan
but most of the things that we planned
not most every single thing that we
planned we got it we sat down in the
table
you obviously said what do you want so i
think the best thing is
and that's the way that i live my life
right now is that you know that first
day
we actually paint a picture of what the
end gonna look like
um and we forced it to happen we had
many hurdles many trials many
tribulations but with me and you just
like whatever let's get it done
yeah we forced it to happen in the end
remember you telling me as well
when we were on the first night in fact
while we were driving to my house
yeah you were saying the whole reason
i'm doing this is for ellen yeah you
know
yeah i want ellen to be able to quit her
job ellen's always supported me
and i'm doing this for ellen yeah and um
and ellen did quit her job yeah and and
it's fabulous you guys are now working
together
but why why why why did you have such a
strong reason
um what was the do you know what is
something i mean and that's something
i've never told anybody before but you
know at the beginning of lockdown last
year
i was in a very very bad place i was i
was going for depression not even
you know i was even contemplating you
know suicide i just feel like everything
i was trying
wasn't working every opportunity i just
put everything but it still wasn't
working i was just like what else can i
do you know
i've got a son i'm always saying i'll be
successful i'll be doing this i've been
doing that but after like trying and
trying does it work you know if you're
like
maybe i'm not going to be successful so
i was going down that route now it's
very very down and
you know luckily for ellen she was the
one who pulled me out of it she was the
one who's like look man get up you know
start with your weight
because i was really overweight she's
just like look let's get every single
morning
we start we went on a keto diet um you
were already small you didn't need to
lose weight but we went
all the diet together every single day
we worked out and within like two months
i lost
like about 22 kilos so after that
happened i was just like if i can lose
that way in two months what can i not do
and so i felt like ella was the one
responsible from taking me
from from being on the edge when i went
about to jump off to like bringing me
head something like
like now i'm winning i'm gonna let you
know look i got you and um
you know like you're like you you're
gonna be part of my success so i just
feel like i just needed to show a look
it's not about talk it's now it's now in
action that's great
how how did you guys get together ellen
what's his backstory
so um you came for an interview i was
working at land rover at the time
um so yeah we met atlanta over he came
for an interview and i was one that
greeted you and took you through an
interview
um and then yeah i guess the rest is
history there you've asked me out from
work and
i've played hard to get a little bit
anything yeah
so you met working at land rover and
apparently um
according to one of my members of staff
they said that there's a rumor
that because you guys used to work at
land rover yeah a few years
was it for years ago yeah and because i
bought a land rover
a few years ago yeah we actually knew
each other a long a long time ago
there's lots of conspiracies yeah
there's lots of conspiracies
um but but um just to kind of set the
record straight did we know each other
prior to
um naughto the eviction no at all i mean
i wish we did
i mean the first day i ever met you was
on the eviction yes
yes yes definitely so def we wouldn't
like
we wouldn't i mean if i knew you three
years ago i would not be at the point
where i want to come in suicide
because i would know that if this guy is
successful and he's training people how
to do it i would just just follow him so
i definitely didn't in fact i didn't
even know of your name i only knew of
your name you know just a few months ago
during that watching videos so so
literally um i did not know you i wish i
did
um but i am very grateful now that i do
know you yeah
so so first day we put a plan together
following morning we literally just walk
into some agents
yeah and we walk out with some in
principle rent to rent yep
like so different from my experience
with lawton in manchester i'm sure he'll
come on
winners at some point yeah but like how
did we manage to get
so i mean how many went we must go like
six rent to rent that week
we had we had so many rentals we had an
agent which up to now i haven't even
contacted and i've been so busy sending
me a list of over 20 rental ranges like
this juice
which ones you want i'm up tonight and i
felt bad but i've just been so busy
doing stuff so
i mean how did we do it i think again we
had a plan number one number two
um i mean i definitely just copied and
paste
pretty much what you taught in the
training um you know the scripts exactly
what to say
um and i'm just someone who's just
consistent and persistent so i just like
don't give up
you might shut ten doors in my face but
i'll keep going we ended up getting so
many rent to rent yes within the first
48 hours of the financial freedom
challenge
that i'm thinking i'm thinking we're not
going to be able to
fund all these rent to rents yeah if we
take on too many
if we take on 10 rental rents yeah how
are we going to put the deposits down
for them yeah because each renter
might be a couple few thousand pounds so
i'm like dude we need to
stop at like two or three yeah and
you're like oh i got all these people
and it wasn't just one agent we had four
five six agents we had we had um
director vendors we had people from
gumtree that were like yeah well
and it's like this is just crazy in
london absolutely what do you think it
is about
london that's so open to rent to ants
yeah
i think rental rent is very popular in
london a lot of people are you know
attempting to do rent to rent so i think
what what made us stood out is that
a lot of these agents have heard about
rental rents before but they've heard
about it from amateurs who don't know
what to say and how to say
but the method that we were saying is in
a different way and we have and we had a
backbone we're not begging like please
give it to me but it's like
i'm doing you a favor what are you
saying you want it or not i think our
approach was obviously different to
obviously what they used to and i think
that's
that's what really made it stand out
yeah um in london so
uh you once we got the rent to rent um
which is fantastic we saw a deal selling
we did go through a little bit of
um troubles we had that incident with
the with the like the
lady that was wouldn't let you in the
house because of your skin color which
was just
capsicum would we be able to show our
friend
this apartment
he scares you why does he scare
his attitude
he's very professional my tenant is
english yeah
10 years yeah very very good english
gentleman
very good our only trust in english
you only trust english people but you're
not english yourself yeah i only tried
my
my partner is english i only trust
english people
my wife is african i'm not trust but if
you don't trust anyone who isn't english
the the business owner is evans and
evans is from the caribbean
so if that's going to mean that you
can't do business with him
then we can't do business the thing i
couldn't believe was when
some against some people in the comments
i try not to read the comments sometimes
because
people just freak me out with their
opinions people are like oh that's not
racist
um you know she can do business wherever
she wants to do business i'm thinking
how is saying you're not allowed in the
house
but you are yeah because you're black
and you're white
literally how is that not racist like
at the time it was i didn't know whether
to laugh or cry we kind of we did laugh
yeah on the day about it but i think we
laughed about it just because it was
like
we couldn't believe it it was just it
was kind of shocking yeah
um i mean is that something is that
normal is that something you've
been saying or is that was that a freaky
incident yeah i mean to me i mean the
reason why i laughed i at the time is
because it's happened to me so many
times it still happens to me now
um and i think now i just obviously i
used to just like downplay like but now
i don't
now i kind of like expose you until you
look what you're doing is not right
because i think if
if you tell someone eventually they're
gonna be like maybe this guy maybe he's
right
so so it's not the it's not the first
time it happens all the time
um but i think i mean the good thing
that that we
we documented it is like her it's like
no black guy or black girl has got an
excuse anymore because you've seen i've
i've worked with something you go
through but i'm on the other end now
yeah you know and i think it's really
that's a really important message
because
racism of course it exists same same as
lots of things exist there's lots of
problems same as
not being able to get a mortgage because
you're too young exists
it's a real thing it's a real problem
yeah but i think at the same time
while we need to speak against it and we
need to stand up against it
it's really important to not be a victim
to it absolutely oh because there's some
racist people
i can't succeed yeah what we did was we
said actually you know what
in spite of it we're gonna keep going
yeah and we and we smashed it out the
park
i mean what would you say to somebody
maybe who's watching this um
who might have experienced racism or
feel you know
that that they might be discriminated
against yeah i don't know if you've got
it's hard for me i'm a white dude right
yeah i'm married to a black woman yeah i
got
i got you know mixed race kids yeah so i
get it
but just you know as a black person
speaking to maybe other black people
yeah and of course everyone's an
individual i don't know if you've got
anything you want to say on that because
i mean i mean what i would say about
that is like men like women like numbers
don't lie the numbers if
the numbers stuck up against you know
cultured people um
you know i mean 70 of the uk i believe
it
is white so as much as i would love to
see here and say look there's no racism
and we live in the 21st century okay
unfortunately it's gonna happen
but every individual has got an option
as to what you're going to do
in life you can choose to be a victim
all of your life and be like oh i'm
blood you know whatever
or you can say you know what it is yes
despite of that i'll be a victor
so you can choose to be a victim and
always complain like happening to me or
use that thing to motivate properly to
be a victor
um so i just think like yes they're
going to be obstacles and
and i'm not going to see her and say
it's going to be a smooth ride to become
successful i go for challenges
every day but you have to do it despite
despite that i think you have to do it
um to be a victor to you know to show
people like it is possible despite
yeah that's what i think are you going
to decide on that ellen yeah
i feel like you were more affected by
that than you kind of did i'm like you
always just like brush past it because
you know that in life you always get
more of what you focus on so you used to
always just dismiss it and be like
you know i don't want to focus on it i
just i know i'm going to be successful
or you know
but i think that did kind of affect you
more and we even had like another
incident recently
yeah so i kind of what happened it was
just something in like our apartment
um like it was someone in the lift was
just like being
like saying like why do people like you
live in the lift yeah it was just
really awful but um but yeah so i think
it's like
maybe it's kind of good like now you're
kind of more aware of it and like more
speaking you've
confronted him with it and i feel like
you maybe before to just say oh whatever
because you're always probably positive
you never want to have an issue and like
you always think like
about like the opportunity in meeting
people i think you always want to see
the good in people so
yeah it's crazy that it happens i mean i
can't
i can't even comprehend it and i think
it's interesting what you said about
ignoring it i get the mentality of
saying
if if if you know racism happens or
whatever just ignore it ignore it ignore
it because
what you focus on expands but sometimes
you know we do need to
whether it be someone who's being racist
or whether it's someone who's been
a hater or you know sometimes there is a
time to be like hey
actually not that that's wrong yeah so
it's a tricky one but you know mad
respect for just rising above it on that
day because i remember when it happened
i remember thinking geez this could
knock evans back
for two days yeah you know and some
people it would have some people would
have just felt like
man i need to just take a couple days
yeah just to really just
calm down over that because it was so
extreme but the fact that you just
we spoke about it we dressed it i called
the woman out on it and said look you
know
that's that's crazy yeah we're not going
to do business with you then
so goodbye yeah we moved on and and
and then we rose above it you know i
mean mad respect for that
yeah um but no it wasn't an easy couple
days
it definitely wasn't it definitely
wasn't but i really appreciate you the
way that you addressed him and whether
you
you you're just because a lot of people
be like that's her choice and just move
on but you definitely like you know
called her out which really gave me
confidence because before i i just used
to like brush it off i never used to
address it um but now i actually torture
i said if someone is
you know being racist you know i said
it's not right what you do it's not
right
um so i think definitely what you did
really helped me
well i was i was actually shocked
because very rare
you know i mean i i was shocked but i
couldn't not say anything
when it was just so blatant it's like
you for real what
um so we've got a couple rent events
we then went to liverpool to try and
package and sell some deals which
just went ridiculously well yeah um what
was the secret to just finding deals
selling deals why why can't most people
do what we did yeah i think the secret
is um it's actually no secret i mean you
advertise it all the time
the secret for me was just the training
i think the training that i had
you know on packaging on seven deals
just was very very simple
and when you say training just for the
record so throughout the month prior to
the financial freedom challenge
um you went through a rigorous training
um process throughout the eviction you
are you're forced to do all of my
training courses yeah um
and then i came out and spent a week
with you live on the financial freedom
challenge
and of course was training you
throughout the week and working with you
um on it and and of course like
training is imperative it's like if you
want to drive a car you need to take
some lessons
um you know absolutely but what were the
big key takeaways then like what was the
what what's the what's the secret what's
the secret the packaging and selling a
deal packaging and selling the deal i
think i don't think it's a secret i mean
number one you need to get deals and get
investors
but i know people who's got doesn't go
investors but they can't do they haven't
got an extra oomph that actually thing
to push over the line
i think i mean for me i mean i was born
in the caribbean i was born in like
uniform from the bottom so i think i'm
used to hustling and
you know kind of like selling my way
through to even eat um so i think i'm
naturally a salesperson
however when it came to selling a deal
for three thousand pounds
it was the opposite i didn't have to
sell i was just like that was that was
too easy for me because i'm just used to
being in your face selling um but the
main fact that
you know things i learned from your
training about the questions to ask and
qualify them and get them to sell
themselves to you yeah
that was that was that was a no-brainer
for me because i i had to tell you many
times i was like stop selling yeah
stop selling you're being too pushy and
you're like oh wow
because people probably think i'd say
the opposite yeah but then i said all
you need to do is ask these questions
and make them sell themselves yeah talk
to me about that
yeah i mean you def i mean that week i
learned i think i learned more from you
indirectly than directly like the way
that you just
word things and the questions that you
asked the tonality
um a lot of those things came through
the training um you know questions such
as
you know what's your current situation
um so when they ask all the questions i
think for me that was a big thing when
they're asking all the questions what is
this what's the prize little
uh cool that's my very good question
before i address these questions
uh do you mind if i ask you a few
questions just to make sure that you
meet the requirements because you need
to go through
you know a mortgage than that what's
your current situation so all of a
sudden they're going to be like
well i've got mortgages i've got x
amount of money in the bank i can afford
this girl
so it was a complaint yeah it was a
complete paradigm shift
yeah from what i thought dill selling
was to actually what deal 7 was um and
i mean it it's going amazing so the
training definitely works and kudos to
you for that that's
awesome have you seen a change in evans
since the whole process
100 and he teaches me like what you've
taught him and i've obviously watched
you know they went down the rent to rent
training because that's what i'm
focusing on so
and i applied the same concept of asking
questions like if i'm closing a tenant
for example
yeah i love that closing antenna where
would you say it yeah
but everything you have to know to close
the business
whether it be and people think oh salesy
but it's like no
you want to run a property business
believe me you better be able to close
the deal whether it be a tenant an
investor an agent all the time you're
closing all the time and that's what i
love about your training like i'll
literally pause it like where you say
you know and that i apply everything you
say to when i've got my
you know i've got my viewings and asking
those questions and again we like
even use the same thing to qualify
tenant before we used to run around do
every viewing and now we qualify someone
to make sure they're serious
you know are they in a position to make
a decision before i go and you know yeah
evans the agents that we spoke to yeah
did you
used to work for one of the agents that
we got a deal
from yeah talk to me about that because
that's also something that's been coming
up on social media
i obviously on the week i don't know
exactly what's what i don't know who you
know who
what's happening yeah explain
that cool yeah i mean i used to work for
um one of the companies companies called
aptus um but i mean the good thing i
like about that work that we had the
week that we had was never about
who we can use what we cannot use we
were obviously just trying to get
financially free and stuff like that now
that
agent um at the back of your videos i
actually applied
for many jobs no one took me but one
interview that was that company
um and they offered me a minimum wage um
the crazy thing they didn't even offer i
didn't even have a contract so i
actually worked with them
and just gained you know just getting
just getting paid and after
three months it wasn't working um i just
i just couldn't be an employee but why
to do it um and uh did i fire you or did
you quit
um so they they actually fired me they
actually fired me
it did hurt but but before they find me
i was arguing ellen should i quit just
like don't quit
let them fire you yeah because that way
they're gonna feel guilty and they're
gonna help your future
i was very nice on the phone that was
good he did say if i ever want
for three months you then got fired yeah
but you it really hurt but you didn't
love the job anyway exactly
um and then while we're out doing rental
rents to be fair we spoke to
a lot of agents we got deals from a lot
of agents yeah
but but but one of the agents that we
got a deal from was this agent but what
are we about to say you had to say
after you got fired and started watching
my videos and you called them yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
i mean while i was working those because
i watching your videos your video is
what got me that job anyway
um but while i was working now trying to
pitch them rent to rent and
they don't understand it but they didn't
want to work with me because they think
it's a conflict of interest
if this guy's not making money he won't
sell my houses or whatever the case
moves
so they gave me no rent i left the job i
called them
they deleted me serious but then with
the challenge
so i so now i get it it backs to sales
i'm like look
i know you said no in the future you
didn't want to call the agent no
at the time because you'd been to them
prior yes and we were in your area
yeah and i was like we need to go to
every we need to go to every agent
yeah and you were like
but we got a deal we did and the thing
is as well
i think it's really important because i
know again people people saying people
love to try and discredit people say
oh the joint venture that you did though
was with ellen's dad
yeah you know oh if only i had a
father-in-law that had
lots but it's like people missing the
point
100 it's like we took you from where you
were yep
which was 23 pounds in the bank yeah one
rent to rent
yeah that you'd got a couple few months
prior which is doing okay
yeah no money sleeping in a single bed
with your girlfriend living in your
girlfriend's parents house
yeah that's where you were when we took
you to
living in a beautiful penthouse yeah
apartment thing in central london
yeah making multiple thousands of pounds
a month with your rental rents
made ten thousand pounds in the week
from packaging selling deals
that's where we took you we didn't start
from nothing we started with 23 pounds
we started with the few connections you
had we started from the little
little experience you had and we took
you from where but that's that and
that's everything
what i'll do in my trip all my training
i'll always say to people you know the
sat nav analogy you'll say where are you
right now yeah
where do you want to go and how we're
going to get there and we're going to be
resourceful we're going to use all of
you
jeez if you've got a father-in-law who's
got a hundred grand in the bank
believe me i'm gonna try and get that of
course get that as a joint venture and
again you weren't sure about that you're
i don't know if you
didn't want to do a deal with me yeah
but yeah because you became investible
because you've got the knowledge you've
got the skills if you've gone to
like when you went to that agent a month
prior and they were like no no
you've gone to to your father-in-law a
month prior he had been like
not surprised that he even said yes i
mean you tried speaking to him before i
feel like
we'd kind of been like drip feeding him
like entrepreneurship
and like you bought him think and grow
rich
i think you can go rich by investing
with me yeah
so i felt like the credibility just
wasn't there fair enough like you know
you're living in house
dynamic wasn't right and obviously that
was like you know
that was inheritance like he lost his
parents and like he never
i felt like he was found it too hard to
even to spend the money like he hadn't
touched it because he just was obviously
like grieving
so i feel like but when it became a way
to like help you and he had the
credibility from you and from
listening to all the training around the
house yeah so he was like actually
listening to your training as well like
because you had it so loud
why do you think people try and um try
and discredit
what you've done yeah like it's
what do you think what's going on in in
some people's minds man it kind of
freaks me out
yeah i mean what it is is that a lot of
people man
you know everybody's going one agenda
nobody everybody loves themselves more
than anything or anybody else in the
world and
and some people haven't unfortunately
to go out there and misunders themselves
out there and take a risk and take a
hell
um and and because they don't do that
and somebody else do that to make them
feel good they will feel like well
you're there
the only way i can obviously be good is
by bringing you down there because i'm
not gonna do whatever it takes to get
there
so if i discredit you make me make
whatever you obviously did look nothing
it'll make me feel better uh because the
ultimate if you haven't got what it
takes to go out there
look man i want to help you help people
every single day if i'm doing this why
you want to bring me down
why don't you just find out what i did
and try and be up there and that's what
i think is i think
it's like they haven't got um they don't
they don't believe in himself
and when somebody else is obviously
women they they try and discredit them
that's what i think it is i totally
agree and i think as well you've got to
take the cards that you've been dealt in
life
yeah and then you've got to deal your
cards yeah we've all got different cards
yeah you know some people's your cards
were 23 pounds
yeah living in a single bed in your
parents house blah blah
we were like right well how can we find
what you have got going for you though
okay you've got one rental rent already
cool so you got a little bit of
experience in that let's start with that
strategy because you know it
right who do you know who do you know
who's got money like that's part of the
process
yeah if i was speaking to somebody else
and they were like oh well actually
you know i've got credit and i can get a
loan out we got a loan out yeah
you couldn't necessarily if we'd have
been speaking someone we're just gonna
use their cards
we're going to deal them and we're going
to become financially free yeah and
regardless of where
you're starting at yeah the goal is
financial freedom believe me if i'm
working with you
i'm going to get you there of course it
might not take seven days yeah seven
days is crazy
for you well seven days might take seven
months yeah but it's gonna
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen um
you know so so
but i mean listen i don't wanna focus
too much on the conspiracies
yeah around you know did you sell me a
land rover yeah it's complete nonsense
in fact i didn't even know who you were
prior to the eviction not at all like
i never met you i didn't even like know
you
madam i saw you for the first time a
couple a few months back
on the eviction i'm like hey what's your
name
so so if you fast forward a few months
you know
we're here but i know you've had a lot
of support as well
yeah and you've built up a lot of
connections i know you've gone on to a
lot more deals
yeah um before we go on to that though
the renter rents that you did get
yeah we've got the keys for them yeah do
you still have them yep still got them
still doing well one is fully talented
the other one uh he's got two rooms uh
vacant ellen did
a few views that many of you did it too
yeah so we've got a lady who's gonna
take it yeah
so she has no money in the bank but it's
pretty much it's pretty much verbally
done
so all the deals that we secured on the
wheat you still got yeah
the only one i haven't got well i won
the rental rents the only uh the only
one was obviously
uh the jv partner which obviously we got
a replacement but
talk to me about the jv partner so you
to your father-in-law
yeah said that he was prepared to put a
hundred thousand pounds into a joint
venture agreement yeah
we did find a house in the week yeah but
someone goes up to you right and you
will and your dad was like
let's go up higher yeah yeah and we
spoke i'm like no
find another deal yeah so you still got
the joint venture partnership there in
place really yeah
and now you're working on finding the
best deal that you can find absolutely i
think right
i mean he gave us 100 grand on the
challenge but the fact that
what's happened with that deal was
because he was through a company he was
a reporter's property
we got our bid and he's just like yeah
keep building but i'm just like if i
keep bidding
the the deal of a certain does not look
as attractive as before
so i i told him he wanted to do it he
was he's like moving he's like let's do
it let's see what he's doing he's like
this is not the right deal
so just leave that one on the side i'll
find another deal i think he actually
respect me a lot more for doing that
because you could have just quickly got
his money and got that deal but instead
you're like actually no
let's get a better deal because we've
been out bid in fact you're talking to
me off camera about how you think that
there's more
investors out there looking for deals
than they're even on deals right now i
don't know what do you think about
for real i feel that ellen been our
experience we know a lot of people we're
always networked every time you get a
deal you just sell it
yeah and you need more deals yeah yeah
there's a lot of competition with deal
there's a lot of people out there
looking for deals so we're just focusing
that's the opposite of what a lot of
people are saying a lot of people are
saying
i've got deals but i can't sell them
there's no investors you guys don't
feeling that
i don't feel like you know what it's
crazy that most of my investors have got
now a lot of them
a lot of them come from people like i
actually knew
but i never knew they had money if that
makes any sense so although my contact
list of
people i meet now but but but the video
i've done with you
gives them the credibility yeah i know
what i'm doing so that obviously helps
as well
i'm not it doesn't help however a lot of
investors come from people that you just
talk to and you just tell him what you
do
and it's crazy i mean my neighbor uh
winston
um he's obviously one of my one of my um
he's not the one that told you
in the elevator that you shouldn't live
there a different neighbor
okay so you wouldn't sell him a deal he
didn't deserve a deal
he's gonna fill me a million pounds
sausage but yeah
if we wouldn't get it but you got people
coming to you all the time
also ellen you quit your job and that
happened
in the documentary well today actually
i quit my job oh my goodness
did you know you were going to end up
hitting your job with that like a
genuine like
wow no way like and i was saying like at
least like i'll do another month and it
was you that were like pushing me
yeah no because so we did the challenge
together the week
then you surprised ellen yeah and again
was that genuine surprise
i had no clue like i mean even then i
was processing when you say it was hours
like how do you mean hours do you mean
it's like as a business thing like are
we going to essay like are we i just
i know you were there what do you mean
what do you mean i was scared to get
excited
and then misunderstand you cried more
watching it back because we watched the
whole we watched the documentary
for the first time live in this room and
my house on tv right
so we're watching it we're watching it
back and in in the documentary ellen's
kind of cool calm and collected
what do you mean as oh that's oh it's
great oh man
but then watching it she's like being
hankies and
yeah you know absolutely balling her
eyes out
because what why was it so emotional i
feel like
just like the way you were just so
grateful to me like i never thought like
i just wanted to support you i know you
were down i just loved you so much and i
just wanted to make you happy so i
didn't feel like you owed me anything
like
um but and and just like hearing you
plan everything the fact that you put so
much thought into it and it was like
because that's what i said for christmas
they didn't give me anything let's just
try and figure out moving out like
yeah i just felt like it was so
thoughtful and i just it was so
emotional
and you've always wanted to live with
city views yeah although more recently
um you're now tempted to get a second
place up north because you can't seem to
be up north a lot of times
yeah houses yeah absolutely i'm thinking
like look i'm always there my mother
based there
um because i i mean i love my apartment
it's my dream apartment but you know
you know not because you know i'm now
somewhere
you know doing well means i need to
relax i'm in a place where i can
put my feet down and change you know
generation so that's the plan
uh the plan is obviously up north in a
base kind of base somewhere about monday
to friday
and i come down the weekends that's so
cool yeah so you've gone from
in a your girlfriend's parents little
single room showing a single bed yeah to
a beautiful apartment oversea
in london and now you're thinking we
need to be now north of wow
we're going to leave the apartment now
okay what do you really need to do you
need to get a helicopter
yeah yeah you can go back and forth 100
but
how's business going our business is
going well man business is going well
man i mean
don't get me wrong there's a lot there's
a lot of downs um there's a lot of ups
and downs
but you know just through the things
i've done before in my life it's kind of
prepared me to
to to handle what's happening right now
in business um thinking thinking for
myself
um and the training you know your
training has too much mindset training
as well so we know when there's these
obstacles they all just have the
obstacles you're not gonna
what's been the biggest obstacles since
the challenge because the challenge was
very much
i know we had a few issues and stuff but
it was very much like
bang bang bang bang like ultimate high
yeah it was smooth
yeah then i left
in touch a bit but what's been the
biggest challenges after the week stuff
that
people haven't seen on camera yeah the
biggest challenges was uh
one of them was to get get get the
properties tenants said um because we're
in a national like
lockdown so that was that was a bit that
was a bit difficult
um we pretty much hit we're pretty much
there now um the other challenges was
was um you know
you know a couple of deals actually fell
through um which deals fell for
so some of the ones that you sold yeah
okay
the thing about it is it didn't fail
through because of anything wrong with
the deal
um and the crazy thing is both of them
was after the 14 days
um you know one just changed his mind he
doesn't want to do property
again because he can't convince his wife
uh and the other one just wanted
the money back to invest in another big
deal um
so there's nothing on my end there's
nothing wrong with the deal um they got
changed
they got a change of mind what did you
do did you resell the deal or did you
lose the deal what did you do yes
obviously i lost the deal obviously i
lost i lost
that deal um i didn't lose the investors
um one of them i have refunded the other
one
um i told him i'm going to refund him
and bend mine i don't really need to
because it's contrast
yeah and in terms of conditions it says
after 14 days if they pull out for no
good reason
yeah you know they're not entitled to a
refund so you did it anyway just because
you wanted to uphold your reputation
absolutely which i think was a good
thing to do yeah you know you're
building your brand and you're building
your business
yeah um okay so yeah deals full throat
which is painful you have a tough time
getting some
some of the tenants yeah which is also
you know is tough
i know it was like a week after you got
a load of tenants moved in real quick
though did they stay what happened with
those tenants yeah no
the tenant the tenant did stay it's just
like we had some actually paid
to move in they paid their deposit and
everything and everything in place and
it was the last minute did they change
their mind
so that was that was a punch in the
stomach but i'm used to being punched in
my stomach my stomach is made up still
because of what the punches have got so
yeah i just obviously just like you know
keep going through but that was the
bounce
what was that like with the tenant side
of things like in terms of
how easy was it to fight to find the
tenants was it that
people kept looking but it wasn't right
for them or i mean what what
happened during because i know that's
you're very much your bag
um yeah i mean because we initially had
someone who wanted the whole place for
all his um you know workforce so it was
gonna
be one person essentially took it all
straight away um and then he changed his
mind
i mean partly it's like people not
wanting to come for viewings with corona
and then when you have current tenants
wanting to be careful about their safety
in terms of doing
additional viewings so that's like one
factor and we just found that
maybe the demand wasn't as high or
people i don't know we just found it a
little bit more difficult than we did
with our previous
one but i think you don't it doesn't
mean it's not going to work you just
might need to put in 10 times more work
you might spend so many more messages
or whatever it is yeah um what about the
other rent around how
how did that that one rent out easier
harder was it the same sort of story
yeah so no it was it was it was again
again again the tenants
um but i mean one rental is already
fully filled the other one has got two
rooms empty we had two viewings today
which all went well so fingers crossed i
mean by the end of this interview we
should be fully tenanted however
we obviously had to put in the world but
the good thing about it is when i
initially caught the rent to rent i want
to go a month free
so it didn't pin me financially at all i
didn't pay for the rent of my pocket
the even when i got three weeks off it
so it didn't pin it up financially at
all
it just paid me in the sense that i was
had so many investors who wants to buy
deals with me
but i was more focused about getting the
tenants and getting a property filled so
i think it probably cost me a few grand
because i didn't really
however it's a learning curve i've
learned a lot from me and um obviously
moving forward now we just we just
you still got them they're making money
one of them stuck the room's stuck a bit
longer than you thought
yeah you know and that is sometimes that
does sometimes happen yeah
sometimes the nature of property yeah um
how about the deal selling how
the deal selling side of the business
being i mean those selling man why am i
i mean if i knew you can just make that
much money and deal selling man i was
just like why would i ever
you know ever do anything when i came i
took in 2014 i'll go straight into the
cell and if i knew that's what it was
but um but yeah it's changed
uh it changed my life man i mean
yesterday i was just viewing the
property
and just for deal selling actually
secured at least option agreement it's
getting very very good
make good money good connections i have
loads of people wanting to call the
resource with me
i'm fully compliant so man i'm happy man
yeah in terms of numbers and stuff how
much money are you making on the deal
selling side of things or how much money
have you made in total
since you started the challenge yeah so
um i mean i mean
i've even lost some kind of mean 10 uh
16
and nine that is uh uh 34
i've been free grannies so i made about
37 thousand pounds um
since um you know since the challenge
and stuff like that
and and that's the two of you working
full time yeah you know it's not passive
yeah very very active very active yeah
yeah a lot of work
but 37 grand over the space of what
three months yeah yeah if it's not what
we want to do
so yeah it's not bad and and bear in
mind we've never done that before we
just three months just follow your
training and obviously now but now we
obviously have experience because we've
obviously made a few errors
do you think you'll carry on making that
kind of money or do you think that you
went crazy to begin with and
and now you have more of a trickle or
what's the kind of projections
i don't think i'll carry making that
kind of money i think i'll make a lot
more money man oh you didn't went more
than that 100 percent like my
goal because the way you kind of told me
that you like added it up in your head
and you're like
it's been uh yeah 37 like you didn't
sound that excited by
making 37 grand in three weeks
considering that when we met you had 23
pounds in your bank
it's just definitely you've had a
mindset shift yeah
you've been hanging around me and the
folks too long yeah you've been hanging
out
with 37 a month you've changed your
thermostat 100
100 i can recall i was actually seeing
right where you are and you were
standing you seen on the floor
and you were saying the reason why
you're doing these videos the reason why
you're doing the eviction is to really
help people change their thermostat
and you give the example of amanda said
set it to 24
and that really hit home that really
yeah i mean you actually said that look
every individuals go a famous start like
for example amanda's
you know thermostat in the house is 24
degrees if you open up the window
it might drop down but it doesn't really
matter because it's always set to 24
it's always going to go back to 24.
and once human beings are set to a
particular number that they feel they
can make every single month
and even if they make five grand this
month they'll go back to what they
normally make
so your goal is to change their family
to get them to think
bigger and from then like my family said
right now is free for what was free
grand then
now you know it's 15 25 pounds
everything come up it's changed
a lot and being around you and being
around the mentors is even growing
a lot bigger yeah so that definitely was
a huge you know quote that they
um that's incredible that you've managed
to change your your money blueprint
and that's where you quit your job man
you how much were you making at your
previous job at ellen
so i mean it was a basic there's like a
low salary of like
14 grand or something basic yeah the
commission on there but it was the same
thing where deals would fall through so
in theory i was making in a year i
remember you said it you said
evans could make in a day what you're
making in a year
thanks for that thanks for that but it's
good you may not realize that you helped
us change our thermostat so yeah because
we were saying we sold like a couple
deals
like man we could literally make ellen's
annual salary
yeah in a day yeah and ellen was like
thank you
but it's good you need to hear those
things but then you just couldn't
continue working your job after that
yeah and it was i mean the hours were
like ruling anyway and then like i was
needing to like
you know take on more responsibility
with the rent event so that you could
actually have time for the deal selling
so
you would it just it just made sense
really so what happens now what's the
plan
so the plan is to you know continue
making money but
i mean i really want to focus on my
mission of helping helping helping
people
um you know working with people
inspiring people and
let people know it doesn't really matter
where you are when you can do it man
that's what that's my
now i think i'm making a lot of money i
think it's going to happen organically a
lot more
i'm stumbling on deals just for deal
selling so that's going to happen
organically i mean i've got my goals for
figures of stuff
but now i'm not focusing on on my on my
on
on actual things that actually mean a
lot to me like my mom's house i go
finish it
my goal is in the next few months go out
to lunch and finish it that cost me
fifteen thousand pounds i want to build
the mosquito lucia
um i want to be on stage to help people
so i think the money is coming i mean
before i was all interested about money
but now the money just coming
organically so now focusing on the
things that well it's crazy how quick
things have happened because you
you know you were a couple months ago
yeah really keen or just before the
challenge you're like oh my gosh you
know asking me how to stare and
russell or all your questions and
anthony um
and and your knowledge was okay do a
little bit you've read some books and
cds but then
we changed your thermostat and we and
now i get people messaging me
like they don't want to speak to me
anymore they want to speak to you
they're like hey can i speak to evans
about
how he sold so many deals to speak to
can i speak to evans about this
i'm like holy moly i i've even got you
one um i've even got you now on samuel
365
hey anyone wants to speak to evans um
you know
you i've now officially got you down as
one of the people that answer questions
and help people
which which which you've literally just
started doing
like today yeah literally today so today
someone you spoke to one of our samuel
365
um members they're asking you about what
will they ask you
uh about deal selling but illegality is
about deals and stuff like that and
people might
what would you say to someone that says
how dare evans
um advise people and and tell people
about
deal selling and answer their questions
he's only been doing it in five minutes
what what what a yeah because
i would say there's a point actually
there's a point where i agree
yeah you know like you know you
shouldn't really be trying to teach
people
yeah when you haven't got experience
yeah you've been in the game five
minutes yeah
so we we've got you on the panel
yeah on samuel 365 and the reason i put
you on the panel
was because everyone was saying to me i
want to speak to evansville evans
started off when i we're running out
wednesday evening q a coaching session
and i was like let me bring evans on you
can't it was like oh my gosh because
i've watched
the documentary so everyone starts
picking your brain asking me questions
you get a lot of value
yeah you know yeah and even though
you're brand new
you're a lot good stuff to say yeah
that's fresh good stuff to say
you know so we put you on the panel but
what would you say to someone that was
like
that you know how dare you try and tell
others how when you've been in the game
five minutes you sit on this panel of
samuel 365 like
how would you defend that i mean
everything in life is about perspective
it's all about how you look at something
and you can say you can turn around you
can say hey
ever be in the game for five minutes
maybe he doesn't know much
or you can say okay let me hear what
he's got saying let's see if it's of
value but for me the way i look at it is
this i mean look
everything i'm saying it's not something
i've read in a book or watching a video
things i've actually done and i'm
actually doing
but i mean there are times where i'm
going to come across things that i don't
know but the amazing thing about being
part of the panel
is is that i've got people with
multi-millions accessible to me i can
always call you
always call anthony always call alistair
you know that's part of being on the
panel that's part of being on the
whatsapp group so
you know by speaking to me if anything
for someone getting started it might be
a lot better for you why because i can
speak your language i can relate to you
i'm very different to you so it's about
perspective i think that's right though
i think you're you're
you're sitting with a group of mentors
yeah you know
yes people can speak to you and ask you
questions but then if you don't know the
answer
or if but it might be something you
totally the answer to might be like hey
look i'm struggling to sell a deal to a
new investor
i'm just getting started and you're like
actually i can write to that but you're
doing it under the umbrella
of samuel lee's training yeah with with
our principals with our panel of mentors
in a safe environment yeah um you know
so i actually think it's quite exciting
and i know that you love doing it yep
you know so
yeah it's uh it's more than a gold medal
it's crazy that is you know ways i i'll
tell somebody every day man samuel is
not a mentor trainer someone
is probably a magician because you came
to my house and and and you saw my
vision board
and you saw i want to be a speaker you
saw i wanted to leave i want to move in
the house
and you just you didn't do anything i
didn't want to do you really helped me
do the things that i always wanted to do
so man i'm just i mean i'm i mean i'm
grateful i mean i said all the time i
think
preparation is opportunity i've been
hoping praying many different things
that doesn't work
and finally i get somebody like samuel
and i got this trading
and it's just like it's like magic yeah
what are you thinking ellen
a hundred percent yeah like i said luck
is like preparation meets obviously
and that's like ask me like it's such a
best thing like we discovered your
videos in
in lockdown and like we were really at
sink or swim at that point
so yeah and it's funny because you write
the dream board when i come around your
house
in this little little small room a
single bed but you're both sleeping
your son comes you have to sleep on the
floor but then you've got a little dream
board
yeah and i'm looking at the dream board
and i'm seeing all the different things
and out of the 10 12 things yeah like
pop
bar one or two which would be completely
out of our hands
yeah every one of them has pretty much
happened yep
yeah pretty much happened it's crazy man
it's crazy i think you know i mean i'm a
strong believer in god i believe in god
i'm going to preach about god but
god is the reason why i'm here but god
is you know haven't seen him i think god
came into you use you to to meet me and
speak to me i think i think
you know you know it's all god and i am
grateful
um and i did say to god when i was
praying when when everything was done
like look god
if you help me now when i make it i'll
tell everyone it was you so now
afternoon when he was god
um and god came in the sign of you so so
that's great that's great and i'll tell
you something as well though
um you know yes i've helped you and
given you a bit of a break
but everything that you've achieved is
down to ultimately it's done to you guys
is hard work your commitment your
persistence
i mean there's a lot of people i could
stay in their house for a week
and then move out and then they'd lose
all the money yeah they'd mess
everything up
you know and the reason i chose to do
the financial freedom challenge with you
was because i believed in you as a
person i saw your work ethic which was
through the roof
and i'm just you know really really
happy and you guys are just a nice
couple man
like you know i know we've um you know
we've hung out a little bit socially and
done things but
you know you guys are just such a great
couple what would ellen what would you
say to someone watching this
who's thinking you know what i'm i'm
like how you guys were
a year ago you know bad place got any
money
it got a big dream but don't actually
have to get there
what what advice would you give to
somebody um i mean i would just say for
us like you know we started with the
youtube videos and then being able to
the training itself like i said it's got
everything it's got the mindset as well
as all the tools and all the steps that
actually
you know take action and and really you
know i mean i spent
so i think when i think about what i
spent on my university degree and what i
got out of that compared to what i got
from your training it's just crazy like
it's a huge
investment in yourself and what you'll
get back for it will just
you know will be tenfold um what about
you evans what would you say to someone
watching this
yeah and and i think what are the first
steps i can take yeah
i mean i mean what i'll do is just tell
him exactly what i did um
you know i i i put all my faith in the
creator he was
obviously when i prayed when everything
was going wrong and i think he spoke
together to me look everyone's i want to
help you but you have to help yourself
so i started doing the dream board i
started doing the affirmations and
started praying and hoping
but even those things was good but it
wasn't you know like i still have to do
my part because it's all good and well
to read the books and watch the videos
and all the rest of it but
like god wants to help you but you have
to help you and i think
by me putting myself out there by me
obviously getting trained and by me
obviously meeting you and
you know it just happened um so i think
like yes it's always good to write your
stuff down have visions have goals
but at some point like you need to put
yourself out there
like get trained i'm like i can't like i
can't emphasize how important it is to
get trained because i think that's the
biggest difference between me now and me
six months ago
i'm no less passionate i'm no less
hungry i'm not
i i wouldn't say work ethic but now i am
motivated but i'm not motivated in the
wrong direction i'm in the right
direction why because i've got
the training i've got clear vision um
so yeah man you know number one have a
plan as to what you want to do but at
some point you have to get trained you
have to get knowledge get a mentor
and just get it done man if i can do it
someone like me black guy
you know i've been in the country since
2030 that's less that's about just over
seven years ago
i've still got accent hardly go any
family in this country if i can come
here and i can obviously do the thing
i'm doing
you know why why not you i never been to
university i didn't finish college
i mean no excuses just what exactly what
you've done
um and anybody can do it yeah that's
what i would say just for a proven
system
yeah and you have got a lot of passion
and a lot of hunger but you've always
had that yeah
you know but that passion doesn't stop
you getting eaten alive in the boardroom
not at all what happens what happened
in the boardroom when you came with your
business uh in the boardroom i got
ripped a new one i i i got ripped apart
this whole thing confused me i have no
idea what you even planned to do
but you're not going to get any money
but you know it was very very good man
it's very very good in the sense that it
just really made me just you know what
happens you know what
yes you're hungry and but there are
things you need to get straight up so i
think um you know jl
was now a business partner i know how
crazy so jl was there ripping you in the
business
in the boardroom meeting but then she
she's now
doing business with you absolutely and
it came from a place like she
wanted to see you win yeah that's the
case with all of us though even alex
there
yeah i mean i get criticized a lot for
being too hardcore
even at the crash course people are like
man you know you really hardcore or
i'll tell people straight but i think
the reason is is because i don't want
them to like me yeah i don't want to be
their friend yeah i want people to
succeed
yeah and and other people might not like
it and i'm sure you didn't love it in
the boardroom
100 respect no i can't respect it you
know what
you know what i really like samuel is
this like you know about people around
me was you know claim to your mentors
and stuff like that but
they didn't they would never harm me
they would always tell you the things
that you want to hear or you're a nice
guy
burns you know you're very passionate
like cool i get it but that's not for me
to get to
my next level what's going to get me
there someone who's brutally honest
and tell me what i've got what i've got
to improve on that's the only way i can
get better so yes in the bottom it was
it was like it was very bad however
like you you're in tears it was that bad
he never cries
yeah but you i've never seen you crying
all the years you've been together until
it came back absolutely 100
i mean right after that i bought the
book on how to
draw a business one and then when you
came you saw our house
yeah i did i didn't see it for oh
brilliant so yeah man i definitely
deserve that that that
so you keep talking about the training
yeah people might be thinking yeah but
evans
and helen we can't afford to do the
training people seem to have this
idea people think that my training
costs tens of thousands of pounds and
it's really really really expensive
and it's only for either rich people or
people that just have to get into lots
and lots of debt and yeah
i don't understand why people think that
because my training is actually
really really cheap really cheap i mean
the crash course is a pound
yeah and then i might sell you on doing
some further training
for 95 pound on sample 365 yeah all of
our courses cost 995
which okay maybe it is expensive but
just to somebody but yeah if you want to
do rent to rent
you want to go through all the rent to
rent training it's actually not even
995. the rent event training is
how much for 4.95 495.
i should probably do a youtube video
where i just say these are all the
prices of my courses folks and just give
all the courses all the because it's
actually
pretty cheap yeah
yeah but like tell me about what signing
with 365 is because now you're actually
on the panel you know as an advisor and
a mentor which is just crazy
yeah um but but tell me about what is
samuel 365
i think samuel 6 365 is not not i think
it's definitely because i've been for
many you know many trainings and stuff
like that
so i think that was the best mentoring
training platform out there
and here's the reason why you know it
costs you less than a thousand pounds
cost like 95 pound you know a month
um number one and not only do you have
evidence as a mentor
you have some
so all together amalgamated together you
have millions guys worth millions
mentoring you you can use them 24 7 15
minute calls
unlimited time most importantly they get
to get you for week
every single wednesday um i mean it's
it's it's insane
the whole community yeah yeah because
normally let's say you pay a mentor
i know two grand yeah and that's like
i'll mentor you for three months
yeah and you're calling them back and
forth and all that and
you paid two grand but then you might
about to get ahold of them or they could
be a bit busy or exactly whereas
you just paid 95 a month exactly you've
got a whole panel of people
exactly call them anytime one on one
yeah one-on-one yeah training mentoring
weekly calls with me
networking lots and lots of training
worth thousands of pounds
on the platform for like a month no
excuses
no issues and if you're not sure we have
a seven day trial where you pay a pound
one pound and within that pound you
still can do calls
within that pound you can still you know
go on the crash course you know go on a
crash course
and still speak to you i'll still be on
the the zoom call and you know what i
think about
and i think i'm sure that's the reason
why you have all kind of successes
because
the good thing about the 365 is that you
have different characteristics from
different parts of the world so
i'm a strong believer you might be a
very universal key but there's no key
that opens
every single door you might be a great
speaker but maybe you can't relate to me
because you've never been
you know in the guts but but you have
you you have me there's different
characters that can obviously adapt to
different people
and that's the benefit of being called
every ship size
you know ethnicity men women men women
different races different religions
come on standing with people helping
people
you know and i guess as well it's kind
of like there's no better option
if you want to get a property mentor
there's no other option
exactly where for 95 pound a month can
you have access to millionaires
yep they don't know what it's just
ridiculous it's insane it's just totally
it's a game changer no it is and he's
made it impossible for other training
companies
yep if you've got if you want to set up
a property training company how can you
compare
exactly how can you compete with 95
pound a month when you've got direct
access to millionaires yeah
it's just like it's crazy crazy 100 it's
going to change
and as a result more and more people
we've got more winners wednesdays now
lined up than we've ever had before
you know and that's one thing that no
other training company can do
not at all no one's doing women's
wednesdays not at all only our company
not at all
because we're the best and you've been
doing it for so long now
that's really really inspiring of course
man i mean you you can say where
like i met someone they've listened
about some samuelson i'm just like cool
i get your opinion that's fine no
problem at all
but maybe you've been a little bit
emotional let's talk about a little
let's talk about facts like
you understand like because when your
emotion is high your logic is low
all right let's talk about logic
logically whether you like the guy is
key in the color whatever you might
think about him let's talk about the
numbers
which trailer that you have documented
has got all of these winners
documented on youtube that you can't
deny that the guy's trading works like
whether you like him or not i don't care
about your opinion
get your logic out of the way like get
your emotion out the way it's about
logic logically
like numbers don't lie it's so true and
i'm a documented millionaire
like there's a lot of people out there
faking or trying to predict like
i started documenting my journey before
i was a millionaire yeah right back in
2014
and i documented my way to becoming a
millionaire and then i documented my way
to becoming a multi-millionaire i'm
documenting everything i do videos every
single day
and it's like no one's ever done that
before exactly i love doing it
i love seeing people win yeah the
satisfaction you know
i came and lived with you for a week you
didn't pay me for it no i did it
for the pure satisfaction and uh it was
a fabulous week one that i'll never
forget
yeah 100 that week that was the week of
my life
we're forever grateful that was the week
i mean there's a quote that says there
are
there are years when nothing happens in
your life and there are days when years
happen
and literally that week years happened
like i can't
explain what's happened since then like
i'm like a celebrity
probably you was were you getting
stopped on the street now yeah i got
stopped in sainsbury's last night by two
security guards
so so i'm walking i'm walking in the
store there's two guys following me
one's black one's white um
so okay it's cool no no no she wasn't
that's all the way in leaves actually i
went to
i want to find a deal so when it comes
to the cashier i had a guy saying
um is that him is that him so i turn
around i was like what do you mean is
that me like
like what have i done i haven't like i
haven't got no pockets and he's still
like what happened
uh he's just like are you from some of
you ladies youtube
videos and i just i was just laughing
the reason why i was laughing is because
about nine to ten months ago during a
lot of time i was working in max and
spencer's
i'm on the a46 in north london in as a
security guard
right and now i saw anthony joshua
um while i was working there and i was
like anthony joshua let's take a picture
i put a picture of my instagram
so i actually felt what they felt when
they saw me it was just like can't
believe it's you man
why how is the apartment how's ellen how
some you know
like and and and and for like two
minutes guys look man i know you're
excited but
i promise you i was exactly where you
were a few months ago
you've been to the crash course just
take action and let's see what it works
so these guys had already been to the
crash yeah they've been to the crash
cause they're like yeah i've been there
i know samuel
you know i've done the crash because i'm
like have you done the crash course or
you've been to the crash cause because
you're gonna do the crash because like
go to church
go every single week until you get it so
uh so yeah i think they're pumped and
hopefully they should
get a lot of people like spotting you
messaging you on social media doing
business with you do you feel that
from a marketing and branding
perspective is it is it helping your
business
oh tremendously that's crazy good
tremendously i'm about
people telling me i've got x amount of
money they showed me a proof of funds
just invested so that's probably why
you're finding it one of the reasons why
you're finding it so easy to sell deals
yeah because everyone knows who you are
exactly and grant cardone says the first
thing you need to get is you need to get
people's attention
yes so um we've certainly got that i'm
glad to see
you're delivering that as well so hey
guys what a what a pleasure
thank you so much for coming down to my
house so much thank you
yeah i look forward to seeing the next
few months yep getting back for an
update in six months
absolutely looking forward to it awesome
guys i hope you enjoyed the interview i
think you can agree
they're an absolutely fabulous couple if
you want to see the entire
documentary that we did you can check it
out on the video right up here
absolutely incredible check it out and
share the heck out of it
if you want to see more women's
wednesday interviews like this
you can check out an entire playlist
here over 100 people have been
interviewed just like evans and ellen
and don't forget to subscribe right here
thanks so much see you next time